Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update Lucasfilm has announced that
going forward All Star Wars media will
be part of official Star Wars Canon
including games except for the two movie
trilogies and the animated Clone Wars
series All Star Wars media all the
comics books games and so on have
existed in the expanded universe which
has never been officially considered
canon today Lucasfilm announced that
quote in order to give maximum creative
freedom to the filmmakers and also
preserve an element of surprise and
discovery for the audience Star Wars
Episode 7 through 9 will not tell the
same story told in post Return of the
Jedi expanded universe not only that but
with the help of a new internal story
team all new Star Wars media will now be
part of official canon nothing is really
changing with the pre-existing expanded
universe stuff it'll still be considered
non-canonical including Star Wars The
Old Republic a Lucasfilm representative
told GameSpot as far as the old republic
MMO is concerned the Old Republic has
always been a part of the expanded
universe that's not going to change
however the rep also told GameSpot that
future game releases will be part of the
official Star Wars Canon this includes
dices battlefront and visceral new star
wars game being written by former
Naughty Dog creative director Amy Hennig
and uncharted actor Todd stashwick this
also means that star killer and HK 47
two of our favorite Star Wars video game
characters are strictly expanded
universe let us know in the comments
below if they're betraying all the
Expanded Universe fiction you know and
love or if you could really care less
about anything that's not episodes four
five and six
you